got breaking news from afghanistan where
an earthquake that struck along the
pakistan border overnight has killed
more than a thousand people according to
one government spokesperson in that
region the afghan government says
hundreds of other people are injured and
there is a frantic search now for
survivors the quake has turned homes
into rubble in that mountainous region
and our holly williams is tracking the
ongoing rescue effort holly good morning
to you what do we know
good morning well the earthquake hit at
around 1 30 in the morning local time
meaning many people were inside asleep
and vulnerable when buildings collapsed
that may have been a factor in how
lethal this quake appears to have been
the magnitude of the quake was around
six and the epicentre was roughly 200
miles southeast of afghanistan's capital
kabul social media video videos show
shattered homes and a helicopter
evacuating the injured but it's a remote
region afghanistan is mired in poverty
and this comes around a year after the
taliban seized control of the country
prompting some aid groups to leave and
setting off a humanitarian crisis all of
that is going to hamper rescue efforts
afghanistan has a long history of deadly
earthquakes in 1998 one quake killed at
least 4 500 people gail
thank you very much holly